joining me via Skype this week is ayaan
Hirsi Ali I hope that most of you
already know ayaan but in case you don't
her story is truly an incredible one
that takes her from a childhood in
Somalia to an elected member of
parliament in holland to a fearless free
speech advocate hated by both the
extreme right and the regressive left
will dive deeper into her life's
incredible journey shortly but before we
do that I wanted to take a moment to
talk about why people like ayaan
actually matter as our show has gained
momentum here I realized that what we're
doing is really becoming an influential
force for the things that I believe that
mattered namely the Battle of ideas free
speech and liberal values at the end of
the day though I want this to be about
more than talk because the repercussions
of these ideas that we're talking about
aren't just abstract notions there's
stark realities for so many people
ayaan Hirsi Ali is a survivor in every
sense of the word she survived genital
mutilation as a child she survived a
forced marriage to a cousin she survived
the cold-blooded murder of a friend in
broad daylight in Amsterdam and
subsequent death threats many people
would have given up after any of these
horrific events many people would have
just accepted that this is what life has
given them and remained quiet many
people right this very second are doing
just that by the way I find no fault
with these people who remain silent
under such subjugation they see no way
out and sadly even those in the secular
world who want to help them fear the
repercussions if they speak out not
ayaan though she has bravely and boldly
fought for women's rights brought the
issue of female genital mutilation out
in the open and relentlessly made her
life story a cause bigger than herself
it's easy to sit back and privately talk
about these things or tweet about them
from the comfort of your own home but
she's actually out there putting her
life on the line after they already
tried to take it from her I want to be
very clear here that when I talk about
these issues I'm talking about ideas and
not people this seems to be a major
sticking point in this conversation and
I really hope that we can eventually get
past that not just for the health of the
debate but for all the young people
currently being indoctrinated with this
ideology imagine if a political party
had a platform that included female
genital mutilation
in forced marriage and death for
apostates absolutely insane and
ridiculous right well guess what
religious ideas cultural ideas any ideas
deserve the exact same scrutiny no
matter how uncomfortable it makes us I
for one would rather live in a society
that deals with uncomfortable truths out
in the open then one that leaves huge
portions of people alone in the dark
I'm here with ayaan Hirsi Ali human
rights activist and author of the new
book heretic why Islam needs a
Reformation now I and welcome to the
show thank you thank you Dave thank you
for having me on so I'm gonna show all
my cards right up front here I'm such a
huge admirer of yours and I think you
you've done such good work and you and
your story's amazing and your bravery is
amazing so I'm gonna hold nothing back
and just set us off on that on that good
welcoming note is that okay with you
thank you thank you for having me on
again and thank you for everything you
said so there's a ton that I want to
talk to you about and so many of the
things that your life is an example of
are the things that we've been talking
about on the show here for months now
and I know many of my guests have been
people that you're you're friends with
and and co-workers with and have done
speeches with but your story is the most
unique and most interesting and I want
to talk about the book but I thought we
could just spend about 10 minutes just
sort of on your biography and I know you
you've discussed it a lot and that's
what one of the books is about but if
you could it's so illuminating to sort
of how you got here so if you could just
tell me a little bit first about growing
up in Somalia and let's just start with
that well I was born into Somali Muslim
household and if I look at my journey
from I was born in 1969 November my
family went to Saudi Arabia we lived in
Ethiopia we lived in Kenya and then I
went to the Netherlands and now I live
in the United States of America I think
if you look at my geographical journey
it is really nothing unique about it
today people from all over the world
move to different places learn different
languages and adapt to different
situation
I think that what Westerners find
interesting intriguing and maybe in some
ways disconcerting is the intellectual
journey I was raised as a Muslim I was
raised in a clan or tribal society and
the moral framework that prevails there
is that of honor and shame and it's a
different kind of honor and shame from
what we believe here in the West which
is you know as a little girl at the age
of five my genitals were cut and when I
was old enough to ask why did that
happen my grandmother was very you know
she readily explained it as well we
purified you and if you are not purified
you will never find a husband so that
kind of practice is in this isn't
something that happened only to me it
happened to and it happens according to
the United Nations numbers to 98 percent
of Somalis Egyptians Sudanese and so
that's one thing that people find
fascinating how could you have endured
something like that and come out of a
cultural context like that and then fast
forward when I'm 22 years old my father
returns from a long journey he was he
had left us for 10 years in Kenya a
country that if you are a Somali you
feel you know you are in a foreign
country and comes back and he feels he
has the right it as my father to marry
me off to the first suitor the first guy
who comes along and says you know I'm
off the same plan as you I'm looking for
a wife which girl would you like to
offer and then I'm the one who's offered
so to Westerners that seems pretty
strange yeah and I said this person just
to be clear this person was a distant
cousin of yours right which probably
wasn't that abnormal for that area
absolutely not in fact the closer the
kinship the better because the only way
to make sure that family members a loyal
to one another share wealth don't
mistreat one another is to try and marry
within the same family as much as
possible obviously with all the
genetical problems but that's not what
we were looking at but that is that's
the context you know your your roles as
a
as a female that's given as a female you
can bring shame not only on your father
and mother your brother and sister but
the extended family as well and even the
extended religion and so I what is
fascinating for most Westerners is how
could you that intellectual journey how
come once I believed in all that I lived
it and now I'm saying you know as an
individual you have a right to be free
to choose who you want to marry you
don't have to cut off the genitals of
girls for them to be married you don't
even have to be married if you don't
want to because as an economic security
as a woman in the Western context where
there is the rule of Lord where is
freedom and where there's this wonderful
education systems as I go you can
actually choose you know what you want
to do in life you can map out your own
destiny
yeah and that that's why I love your
story so much and why I find you so
inspirational because you're you're
truly living breathing proof that things
can change and that people and and girls
especially from this part of the world
can have a different life and that's why
I find it so wonderful but let's just
back up for just a second on the female
genital mutilation when when this
happened to you did you immediately and
you spoke to your grandmother and all
this but did you immediately question
everything to be that age and go through
something like that how long did it take
before you really were questioning
everything about your life at the age of
five I didn't question it at the age of
ten I didn't question anything at the
age of twenty but I didn't question
anything but there's always as you grow
up and I remember for me in terms of
evolving as you're evolving from
childhood to maturity
it was the ages of 14 15 16 when I want
to know you know what's the point of
this life and why we put on earth and is
it only to reproduce we are you know
that were in my family I we're going
through a lot of adversity and it is
what is the point
what at the point so instead of being
suicidal I joined the Muslim Brotherhood
because they make the points so very
clear you've been put on this earth to
be by God to be tested for your absolute
submission you're going to be tested as
a female in various ways and as a male
in various ways and you just have to say
yes to that submit and earn your points
and for your audience I'm just going to
give you one interesting way in which
think how do they how does one even
manipulate that as a believing Muslim
how does one know that you know you're
doing what God wants you to do you have
two angels on either side of your
shoulders when your height side you have
an angel that notes down minute by
minute second by second your good
intentions versus your bad intentions so
we're not here we're not even talking
about what you say it's really before
you say it but on top of that that same
angel also notes down what you say and
then your behavior and on your left
same thing everything that you do that
is wrong that angel is doing the
bookkeeping and you live and at some
points you die and then there is the
hereafter there's the day of judgment
and we are told as Muslims no one can
escape that your God and his tribe you
know you know before God and his tribe
you know the prophets the angels and all
these other human beings and those two
books are going to be put on a scale and
if you write handbook weighs heavier
than your left hand book you go to
heaven and if your left hand book goes
weighs heavier you go to hell and you
know as you grow up
it's expecially with you know the
radical Islam ization of all things
these things are made so explicit to you
and you become so aware of them it's
like in the West it's like taking
keeping track of your calories yeah yeah
well it's interesting because even the
way you're describing it there's sort of
a whimsy
- the way you're describing it because
now as a secular person it sounds so
ridiculous to you and yet there's
there's literally millions of people
that believe in this in a literal sense
absolutely absolutely and you know you
are young you trust your parents your
teachers your and Islam is your religion
and religion I mean I know that all
human beings who are religious are
taught that the criteria you know the
framework well how do we know the
difference between what's right and
what's wrong religion tells us that and
so as a Muslim in Islam is a way of life
you are taught that this is the
difference between right and wrong and
these things are spelled out that which
is forbidden Haram that which is
permitted halal and so then it's up to
you there's a level of there's a level
of choice in there you know it sounds
like it sounds like the guy on your
shoulder already knows your intentions
anyway right executive so even if you
abstain they still ain't no stealing
knows you want to indulge Wow all right
so I want to talk a lot about I want to
talk it's funny that it seems funny to
you now I'm glad to see that and you
have a beautiful smile so it's nice
because you you've come out of this so
it really is nice so I just want to do
one more thing on your bio and then we
can we can get into some of the
specifics about the doctrine and things
sort of in your life after that so you
you made political asylum in the
Netherlands you then became Member of
Parliament this is an incredible story
of success and you know with all the the
refugee things going on in Europe right
now there's a lot of parallels to that
you you found safety and became
successful and influential and went on
to talk about female genital mutilation
and women's rights and all this
incredible stuff but here of course I
have to mention that then Theo van Gogh
was doing a movie based on a script that
you wrote and he was killed by a Muslim
extremist in broad daylight in Amsterdam
at 9:00 a.m. in the morning and as if
that wasn't horrific enough the the
person that killed him pinned a death
threat to you on this person's body now
I know I know you've talked about this a
lot and I know
people hear things like this and I don't
think it quite gets to them you know it
sounds like a movie sort of right and so
I just want you to talk about a little
bit about it specifically but also just
the feeling that it left you in the sort
of terror because it's one thing to say
these things happen but you're you're a
person that these things actually happen
to well in a way I have to say the
difference between a theory of hunger
and myself was that I believed in those
threats I didn't know exactly what the
individuals who were threatening me
would do so two years prior to fears
death I started to take all kinds of
security precautions and when he and I
were working together I kept saying here
you know I know it sounds surreal in a
Dutch context I think he would tell me
over and over again do you know the last
thing in the Netherlands someone was
killed because of what they believed in
and he would give me years from the 17th
century
like we're Dutch this is the Netherlands
we don't do that sort of thing so relax
let's do this and that was actually true
because because Holland was an
incredible place of mixed cultures and
religions and ethnicities and all that
right absolutely and it wasn't only that
it was also in you know the wider Europe
when in hundreds of years ago 17th
century 18th century when on religious
grounds people would face intolerance so
much as to threaten their lives thinkers
creative people they would go to the
Netherlands and they would get a
sanctuary and so for him it was for fear
in making this film it wasn't about that
yeah it was about preserving what he
knew was his culture his civilization
and and really not just Dutch
civilization I think civilization with a
capital C when human beings can discuss
and can disagree without having to
threaten with force right so in a
bizarre way by by them killing him
instead
have you in a in a weird I know this
sounds perverse or something but that
was more of a direct attack on Holland
right because they were going after one
of their own so to speak so to speak and
I I had I had except that the perimeters
that the government puts me within you
know a security framework which was
really it's something that the Theo
fungos said I would never ever accept
anything like that because these
security measures curtail your freedom
to a degree that you're not free and I'm
not going to accept that and and he
wanted to prove to them it is not having
to you know put a shell around the
people who are practicing free speech
that is not the answer the answer is to
openly discuss these things and make
them open if these people are provoked
by what is that was that particular film
was this is what the Quran says about
women this is how it's put into practice
that's what we need to be talking about
we shouldn't be talking about security
and he gets killed and I think by doing
the murderer killed Theo van Gogh and
that incident confronted Dutch society
and Dutch leadership and I think the
wider European Western leadership with
you know we can all go around saying
talking about the First Amendment
freedom of speech freedom of expression
all this that and the other but what are
we willing to do to preserve it he he
has left us with that question and I'm
disappointed to say that so far we
haven't done that much because as you
know this year the beginning of this
year the cartoonists in Paris were
killed and the threats to free speech
continues and if government policies are
anything to go by it seems as if they
are telling us it's best not to provoke
them yeah all right so I really want to
focus on that because that's been one of
the you know this free speech and
political correctness it's become this
perfect storm that's actually
strengthening everything that it should
be against but just to put a final cap
on your bio and all that what was it
like for you I mean really at the
personal level when he was killed did
you want to just disappear did you want
to leave the country did you want to
give up because now you've lived for
these last
how many years ago was this this was
2000 not far right so I've lived for
these the last 11 years honoring
everything he stood for but I'm sure
there must have been a time when you
thought let me just get out of this
right well I think it every day I think
it all the time it's so tempting to just
think you know I've done enough I'm this
is my age I'm 46 years old next month
there's nothing for me in it
personally but it's I think it's what
Hayek said made the difference between
being comfortable which if I just
disappeared and changed my name I would
be very comfortable versus actual living
which is when you're challenged and when
civilization is challenged when our
freedoms are challenged we always rely
on those who stand up for it and those
who want to push their agenda through
intimidation through force they know
that their argument is very weak
otherwise why would they avoid
discussion why is it difficult for them
to showcase what the Quran and Allah and
the hadith the sayings of the Prophet
Muhammad and the jurisprudence and the
practice of Islam say is about women and
says to women
why are they afraid if women all women
had 100 percent the freedom to choose
and you know if your message is superior
why not keep why not allow people to
just choose for it one of the things
we've really focused on here is what I'm
now calling and what Maajid Nawaz has
coined as the regressive left that there
there are people I come from the
progressive world that that's where I've
been for these last couple years and
it's only really in the last six months
that I've had my own awakening that I
realized it was my guys it's my guys on
the Left that are trying to silence
people like you and silence people like
Sam Harris and and Majnu and all of this
and and I've had Sam
had majid on and I include you in that
and I think partially I think that Sam
said that part or Majid said the part of
his awakening was after a debate that he
had with you what do you make of this
coming from the left because the left is
supposed to debate ideas right we're
supposed to be about ideas free thought
and yet it's those very people who are
trying to silence you I'm amazed by this
I think what I've seen and I could be
wrong is that what the left does is they
put all the emphasis on justice the
concept of justice and maybe what their
rights rather classical liberals because
those are the people I identify with and
in the u.s. they are called
conservatives sometimes libertarians but
what classical liberals do is they put
the emphasis on freedom and I was
exposed to these concepts between say
1995 when I go to the University of
Leiden until 2000 and 2001 something
happiness that makes me intent on
testing these ideas and what I have
discovered like many people before me
and I think you realize as you grow yeah
is that you know there is no justice
without freedom and so if if you accept
and that is freedom from coercion
freedom from being forced into doing
something you don't want to do or using
the tools of states to make individuals
to do something they don't want to do or
the government failing at you know
having one individual take the freedom
of the other individuals but if you have
no freedom then you will have no justice
yeah so so I'm with you on secondary
right so what do you make of the tactics
that they use because there's been so
much we've talked about it so much but
so much lying and smearing about
people's views including your own even
when I when I've just tweeted that I'm
having you on the show
fortunately because we've built
something good here I think you know 80%
of it was positive but a lot of people
she's racist I mean they're telling me
that you are racist so what what do you
make of the tactics that they're using
because I do think they think they're do
something lofty they think they're there
helping the downtrodden or something
like that when in actuality they're
strengthening the very people that they
should by definition be against and I
think that is because if you put the
emphasis on justice you are by
definition going to start talking about
groups and collectives groups and
productive czar abstracts you belong to
a group for you know a short period of
time you're a member of whatever you are
collective you are a member for a
certain amount of time but really all
the time you are an individual so the
basic arguments I used to have with the
left and I started out in the
Netherlands was okay so you want to
protect the culture and the religion of
this collective and this collective is
saying if we don't practice our religion
the way we used to back at home we are
just not happy we feel deprived we feel
persecuted we don't feel at home and
that has all kinds of a psychological
effect on the entire group but what
about the individual what about the
individual girl who's removed from
school what about individual girl who is
forced into a marriage which is
consistently raped she can't reach out
to her parents because they put her in
that situation
her husband thinks he has a higher what
about that individual right what about
the individual right to say I don't want
to do this I want to do something else
and you're forcing this individual into
doing that and these constitutions in
Liberal countries is all about
recognizing that individual freedom and
aspiring to protect it as much as
possible and so what I tell my left-wing
friends and I have a lot of them because
a lot of them have good intentions and
they're progressive and they want to
stand up for the poor the downtrodden
feel the same way yeah it's just take
them back to that unit that they can
empathize with if you're gay and you're
on the left and on the one hand you
belong to a movement you're fighting for
the right in America to marry but on the
other hand you're also fighting for the
height of some minority collective to do
whatever they want to the individual
members shouldn't you be thinking about
the plight of the individual members
those who can't raise their wishes and
those who if they do have
to deal with consequences so die and I'm
not talking about death and threats I'm
talking about your father looking you in
the eye and telling you're no longer my
daughter I disown you you should control
yourself up in the mosque you are not
invited to
so you're shunned and think of the
psychological impact of that on the
individual who chooses to have a
lifestyle that is not in sync with a
seventh century lifestyle right and and
that lifestyle whether they're gay or
just a woman this is what is what the
progressives should always be fighting
for and that's the ultimate irony in
this that's the ultimate irony these
women that I I mean this is my
background I wanted to be free to
determine my own destiny I didn't want
to marry the man I was first in to marry
I wanted to find my own mate in life I
wanted to work and I wanted to finish my
education and I'm still that's going to
bring shame on us now with the emphasis
on us that is the group the collective
so it's always you the individual the
unit and you're constantly being told
you're so selfish you're bringing down
the whole family the whole clan the
whole group and in and here's the irony
I think it used to be the left that
would take up the defense of the weak
and now unfortunately we live in a time
when it is the left that has decided to
define weak units as groups not
individuals so so what can we do what
what yeah
so what can we do people people in the
public sphere with a voice that care
about people on the left they're not
even people on left that care about
liberal values yeah what what can we do
because when I see the tactics and they
were the way they treat you guys yeah I
even I've asked this to Sam and Margit I
said you know there must be this piece
of you that wants to get out and that's
why I asked you to and I partly think
that the reason that they do it is they
want to do enough damage to you guys and
people like you so that everyone else
it's not about you you know what I mean
like they'll get rid of you you'll just
say okay I can't do this anymore
and that but it's the chilling effect
for everyone beneath you so how do we
fight this it's about their utopia I
think what we have to do is we have to
expose the fact that they are after a
utopia this whole justice thing the you
know life would be wonderful if we had
Sharia law all of us it's just uncover
their message really would we and I
think if you are a liberal you have to
revisit the basic principles of
liberalism and it was about individuals
that is how the aristocracy was put in
its place back then when there was you
know I have all of these rights because
I happen to belong to this family and
you're all serfs and you serve us as
aristocrats because you happen to belong
to that collective it wasn't about that
it is about the individual freedom when
it was about you know fighting slavery
you had to recognize the other person
who was the slave as a fellow human
being and as an individual fighting for
women's rights you had to recognize
women as fellow individual human rights
in human beings and the whole concept of
human rights is based on the individual
and the freedom of the individual and we
know that we are social animals and are
social animals and as individuals within
our families and within our communities
within our workplace we have to
negotiate that sweet spot that space
where you can say I can be me and and
this is how I can serve my community and
this is how my community can serve me
but all of that is not going to work if
individual liberty is compromised and
unfortunately the people who have
inherited these systems America
Europeans are the three countries
they're compromising that because they
think it's so you know there's this
collective or that collective and this
story that narrative it is they think
it's they think it's a lofty goal
somehow but I do I do think do you sense
that the tide is turning I feel like you
know the social justice warrior thing
and this whole movement I feel like it's
been gaining strength for the last five
years but I do think partly because of
Charlie Hebdo and sort of the general
absurdity of so much of it online and
you know Brandeis University saying that
they're not going to give you an
honorary Doctorate I mean the the height
of absurdity to not give you an honorary
Doctorate after they said they would do
it that I do sense that the tide is
turning am I just being optimistic there
or do you feel that I think what we are
seeing is more and more confrontations
that really pronounced this this
struggle I I think one of them is Israel
versus the Arab Muslim world here is a
liberal country it's a democracy for
goodness sake yeah and and we find
outside is telling them what they and
they can and can't do who look you know
in the United States of America if we
had people throwing rocks at us right
knifing us if you had the leadership of
the opposition saying you know take a
knife take a car take whatever weapon
you can go after them
we would find it completely unacceptable
and deal with it appropriately but when
Israel does it we demonize and vilify
Israel so it's one but that's one
example yeah and then we have more
examples and you've mentioned magic and
myself and all the other what I I don't
know what is the right time to use
Muslim performers Muslim modifiers
Muslim heretics I think that is the
right word heretic is you're on the
inside you starts to ask questions and
then you're vilified and shunned by this
group because they don't want to change
or because they have an agenda for
Sharia and the Caliphate in Jihad and
you stand up to that and then they go
after you so we're seeing so many of
these confrontations on so many
different levels and I think the mistake
is that you know if you're a socialist
in the United States of you know you're
Bernie Sanders and you're running for
president and you are Donald Trump and
you're running for president you can say
the most ridiculous things in the world
you know nobody's going to kill you and
nobody expects you to be killed and if
you are attacked if any violence against
these two work right now these two
extremes the American population is
going to meet that with such rejection
and it's going to be reviled and we have
to teach the rest of the world that it
is possible to disagree and to disagree
radically but not use violence and less
violence is used so that's an
interesting thought because we always
think or I think we that our system is
so broken here our political system is
so broken and we can't get things done
properly in our discourse is so silly in
cable news but actually the way you just
said that that look you have these two
people who are couldn't be further from
each other Trump and Sanders the
ultimate capitalists the ultimate
socialists yeah and yet they're not
there is no threat there's no credible
threat to their lives right so that does
show that we have something pretty good
about our our Western society I know
it's not cool to say that but that's the
truth right that's the truth and it goes
even more than that we also expect them
to shake hands onstage wakes them expect
them to be civil to one another and they
can disagree as much as they'd like but
you know why is the general public say
the establishment Republicans why are
they angry with Donald Trump I don't
think it's because of his ideas
sometimes it's because of the way he
speaks that goes a little too far it
gets too close to you know uncivilized
behavior violent behavior let's not do
that there is there is a culture here
where yes people are violent there's a
lot of there are a lot of guns out there
and people use use these guns but
mainstream Americans expect mainstream
Americans to behave in a certain way and
it's not a culture that says let's not
disagree we know we all disagree say the
system is broken or it's the human being
that's fragile we disagree what we have
is a system where you can have these
disagreements and these discussions and
you can change your mind you can go as
radical as you please but you are not
expected to use violence and the
government is there to protect you and
with people putting question marks on
the First Amendment there are two
different things this is one part of it
is you know we can disagree with one
another as much as we like but there's a
system here there's an infrastructure
that allows us to disagree with one
another without the use of violence if
you start putting question marks on the
fire
amendment in other words you know
defamation laws there are some religions
or there are some icons that you may or
may not criticize then you are really
eroding the system you're bringing down
the system yeah in this system is
superior to any other system I've ever
seen any other system in history
so our job is and and here's where
people like you and me and Sam and magic
are saying it's we've got to be careful
that the government does not enact laws
where some ideas cannot be criticized
and religion is just an idea it may be
to you everything but to me it's just an
idea and all ideas can be criticized
it makes your idea only stronger it's
not yeah we must not challenge the city
wasn't erode the system that makes that
possible so I'm I'm a First Amendment
fundamentalist if you want if you're
gonna be a fundamentalist of some kind I
suppose that that's the one to be so I
know a lot of people well as I said
earlier they'll call you an islamaphobe
they'll call majid who's Muslim an
islamaphobe what do you make of the meme
of Islamophobia because at one time I
feared that the government was gonna
come for our free speech so infringing
on our First Amendment but what I'm now
fearing is that we're taking it away
from ourselves by what the universities
are doing and by every debate ends in
someone being called a racist right we
know what's happened to Sam that we're
due it's not the government but it's the
peace of words to disciple debate we are
doing it ourselves
you know when the Charlie Hebdo incident
happened I expected all newspapers in
the free world all televisions or all
media to stand in solidarity with them
and republish those cartoons to show
them this is what we do this is what we
are about it's an idea and the
Islamophobia meme if you want to first
of all you know to criticize an idea is
not to be phobic Islam is a religion
it's a faith it's a set of beliefs it's
an idea it's not the people Muslims are
very diverse and many of them disagree
on many things
ruining the position of Mohammed
including whether Mohammed should be
drawn or not drawn criticized or not
criticized so given all of that yes
you're right it's not only the
government we shouldn't give of course
the government is lobbied by 57 member
you know nations of the Organization of
Islamic Conference that through the
United Nations and other international
bodies is trying to make them adopt laws
that leave Islam out of the realm of
discussing ideas and criticizing ideas
but it's not only that we are doing it
to ourselves schools are doing it the
education system the press even
individual I think that some of it is
because we are scared because we think
you know we don't want to be we don't
want to be shot we don't want to be
killed which is just what they want
right they want because the fear is as
powerful if not more powerful perhaps
than then murdering somebody right
absolutely absolutely that's the whole
point of terrorism is to they want to
get what they want so this is so I would
like to promote the idea that men and
women are equal and should be equal
before the law I want to get into every
Muslim community and promote that idea
and I know it's an uphill battle but for
me to do that my life is not safe and
now for the Islamic extremists they
wanted to promote the idea among Muslim
American citizens and others that women
and men should behave in a certain way
they can take advantage of all the
freedoms that we have freedom of
religion of Association of expression
and I give them that yeah but why can't
I do the same why is my government not
protecting me to promote my message
which is 100% aligned with our
Constitution yeah it's so fascinating
because it's so many levels of craziness
I suppose so I think part of the issue
also is that people get a little lost in
the in the definition of terms so could
you explain the difference between the
doctrine of is
so sort of the religious side of it
versus what political Islam is because I
think that that split in itself I think
has many people very confused and that's
why I'm trying to use this show to get
people just to understand the basic
tenants of all this stuff because maybe
that will remove a bit of where everyone
says this is about bigotry and racism
and things like that okay so in the
seventh century a man called Mohammed
comes with a message so man Mohammed the
message submits to one God forget about
all your other gods submits to my God
the one who spoke to me there in that
cave called a hero yes and a bunch of
people say this man is crazy what I'm
going to abandon our gods and he carries
on so for the first ten years what he is
preaching is my God requires you to pray
to fast to look after the poor to be
charitable a lot of the things he was
saying in those first ten years would
fall under what you and I and a lot of
Americans in Europeans understand as
religion you believe in these things and
maybe something good will happen maybe
something good you know you can mobilize
one if you look after the office I mean
what's wrong with that right
that's great right right and then the
next ten years of his life he moves from
Mecca to a place called Medina and he
starts to put together a militia and he
starts to wage war small Wars that he
wins that get bigger and he starts to
conquer and conquer and of course all
that goes to his head and from then on
the second ten years of Muhammad's life
that's when political Islam comes about
when the first ten years he was saying
please reconsider think about having all
these many many gods give them up come
to my one God and would be you a choice
to do it from Medina onwards you had to
do it had to happen at the tip of a
sword and every victory strengthened him
and his followers in doing that and that
happened for centuries afterwards so a
lot of the people today who are using
Islam as a political tool to get people
to do what they want them to do
following Muhammad in this example that
that is why Mohammed is relevant that's
why he needs to be discussed to be drawn
who was he
did he really live is this really what
he said if he said so was it really more
you know moral yeah we should discuss
Mohammed the way we discuss Hannibal
Julius Caesar
you know these were warriors of the past
yeah they Alexander the Great they
established all these empires and then
now they're historical figures that's
how and can we can we do that in 21st
century America without having armed men
around me all the time without fearing
for our lives unfortunately I know what
the answer is to that and by the way a
lot of people on the left liberals
well-intentioned wonderful wealthy
liberals think that the way that they
can make Muslims as a minority feel at
home in America is by respecting their
icon and I think the best respect that
they can pay to their icon is to put him
along with all those other icons of the
past yes isn't that what some are Bill
Maher refers to that as the soft bigotry
of low expectations that somehow we have
to treat these people differently yeah I
want you know I want everyone to be
treated as shitty as everyone else treat
everyone equally crappy that would be
good for me and Bill Maher is you know
he's on point he's one of those few
liberals who is saying I'm not going to
make an exception for my fellow American
sentiment why would I I want them to be
I see them as equals
ya know what and he knows there are a
lot of Muslim Americans would laugh at
his jokes and who love him but they have
to hide that from the Islamic extremists
inside of their families and their
communities yeah so that's yeah and it's
our job to emancipate them by saying I'm
I'm not in Pakistan or Afghanistan or
Somali or Egypt I'm now in America
probably in LA and I want to laugh at
them I like his jokes yeah that's the
crazy part right this that Bill Maher
comes to this discussion is really being
treated like a pariah by the regressive
left and they're calling him and Sam of
course racist because of that whole Ben
Affleck thing but I we've spent so much
time on that I don't want to get into
that look what they've done to bills I
want to say why can't why doesn't Ben
Affleck play the parts of Muhammad
degrade or something like that that
would be something right he had no
problem playing a fallen angel in Dogma
which was all about Christianity yeah
but I guess it's a little a little
different in this case so one of the one
of the other things when I tweeted about
you was that a couple people said how
could you have her on she's a neocon
you're a neocon yeah are you a neocon if
somebody explains to me what a near
carnies they might decide to be a neocon
or not yeah alright so i think i think
what people are saying is that that the
neo-cons they really think of the
neo-cons as the sort of George Bush
Donald Rumsfeld Dick Cheney nation
builders this idea that America can
exert its influence to nation-build and
I think they they lump you in on that
take it away it's a position in foreign
policy that if you are going to
intervene in the and you remember right
after 9/11 you know if we go out there
as the United States of America we know
we've been attacked from Afghanistan we
get into the affairs of that country how
do we leave it now there were people who
were saying we don't just go in and
destroy and get the bad guys and get out
because we leave the situation far worse
than we found it we have a
responsibility to rebuild and it's going
to cost us a lot of blood and treasure
if those are the neocons count me in on
them the fact that such a thing is
really quite murky and it takes a long
time and but I find that position to be
more noble than the position we are in
now where we're going to go and get rid
of defeat and degrade and defeat Isis by
bringing in together people who really
have never fought and have them be
defeated and offer some air power and
just muck it up and muddle through when
the neocons were in charge if that is
president george w bush he did make huge
mistakes early on but after the surge
iraq was under control it's lived in
relative peace we didn't have to pull
out these are political positions and
this is policy and you can say what you
like about the merits of the policy but
I think it is wrong to put labels on the
foreheads of people as neo-cons and this
and that it's not there are a bunch of
people who thought about what would
happen after you leave the place and and
and I still think it's more responsible
once you invade a place to stay there
until things are in order instead of
pulling out two three years into it
right and I guess that's the irony is
that you know we know in retrospect that
the Iraq war was based on faulty logic
but when when we were there it was
better than it is now and that's just a
sad reality and that doesn't mean we
should be there forever but you know we
look it's the United States we're in
this weird thing we do things people
hate us we don't do things and look
what's happening now anyway yeah so I
guess that gets to like they hate us
anyway and I guess that gets your point
about labels so it's also about policy
you see if you are in and maybe and I
can't blame it for people who haven't
been you know in Parliament or in
Pollock weren't involved in policy every
single policy has consequences intended
consequences unintended consequences you
name it so it's all about the positions
you take around these policy issues and
the position you take around a policy
issue should not define who you are and
I think people who then start coming up
with these names of neocon this and and
take it from the policy to the person
they are wrong
they're malicious and they acting in bad
faith yeah and the part of that that
particularly bothers me is that they
think if they can label you with that or
whatever the label is that then they can
extrapolate every other idea that you
think and they think they understand
every other decision that you make which
is so rarely the case many of us believe
in many conflicting things or have
values and libertarian values and so on
and that plus they also distracts the
weaknesses of their policy position so
it's all about not having to discuss the
merits and emails I don't care if my
policy positions I discussed through the
letter and I know that they'll have
weaknesses and they'll have strengths
but in order to discuss the policy
position the policy proposal of the
other person I would never calling this
or that it has to be about the policy
yeah well your your what I would refer
to as a true liberal and willing to
debate the ideas so I know we only have
about ten minutes left and I wanted to
discuss one thing with you because I saw
you I was probably about six months ago
now on The Daily Show when Jon Stewart
was still there and I interned at The
Daily Show in 1999 jon is you know we've
met a couple times and he's given me
some great advice about comedy in life
and I love John just like everyone else
loves John that said I thought his
interview with you was really terrible I
thought every time you brought up
something about Islam again coming from
the history that you come from
coming from your life your first-hand
experience every time you said something
he immediately brought it back to
Christianity he immediately said well
Christianity did this stuff and you're
focusing on Islam and I and it really
was that regressive thing that we
started this conversation about so a do
you agree that it was a sort of messy
interview and B were you shocked because
I I would think everything being equal
that you would sit down with this guy
and he would absolutely love you you
stands for every liberal value and
women's rights and equality and all that
and and I thought it was really terrible
it wasn't funny
deadly wasn't funny yeah yeah it wasn't
funny
it wasn't funny and the reason why it
wasn't funny it was probably because it
was about Islam and Islam is not funny
at the moment and I don't know what
because I can't speculate on what Jon
Stewart's motives were but you know
imagine if the next morning he gets
threats he gets whatever you know people
telling him they he hasn't treated them
fairly you can't laugh at Islam there's
nothing funny I mean I can I can make a
lot of comedy about the absurdities
of Islam and all the absurd things that
are done in the name of Islam but
nowadays that comes you know laced with
threats laced with resentment so it
wasn't a funny show I don't I mean in
hindsight I ask myself why he even
agreed to it but it is it's for him he's
an adult and he he'll probably have his
own explanations in his own lessons yeah
and listen I I know that saying anything
negative or whatever about John is not
going to win me any brownie points but I
thought that not because not only was
the tone of it unnecessarily combative
as opposed to just listening to you but
then at the end he said something to the
effect as he was saying goodbye to you
like basically like I you just want to
sell some books and I really thought it
was just incredibly dismissive and of
course you kept your calm and your cool
and all that well that's funny because
people go to John Wright to sell a bunch
of books but that is I mean I think what
he did in to a certain degree was put
himself in the shoes of my opponents and
in doing so I think the people he
entertains thought that this is not
entertaining this is not funny yeah yeah
interesting all right I think that's the
worst view you can give media yeah
exactly
all right so I have one more for you
that's sort I want to try to tie this
this all together so you know you
alluded to security threats that you
still have you know your life story as
we've said it's just it's just
incredible and an inspiration I think
give me something to end this that we
can all feel good about the direction
that this is going you know we've talked
a little bit about how the voices are
finally raising up in the liberal
community against the regressives and I
think a lot of my audience take solace
in that but give me something that you
from everything that you've lived
through yeah you can really help us all
take with us and and feel good and feel
like feel like we can we can win for the
right reasons and the right principles
well I mean the best news I have at the
moment is just the sheer number of
individuals who are born into Muslim
households who are rejecting the
absolutist submission narrative who are
saying I
I think I don't like it if it comes to
choosing between my conscience and what
Muhammad tells me to do I go with my
conscience and people are paying with
their lives I've talked about as much as
I can arrive by the way in Saudi Arabia
all can you imagine living in Saudi
Arabia and somehow finding the in you
know intellectually the capacity to say
no to all this and stand up for message
of freedom and rationality and reason
and science and then having to deal with
the consequences this man is sentenced a
thousand lashes fifty of them have been
carried out he's fighting for his life
inside prison now he is an icon yeah but
he is only one of what I now see as
thousands and I see them everywhere the
calls the emails I get I am so heartened
by that and ten years ago it was the
opposite every single Muslim who called
me and just called me an infidel and
told me you deserve to die and now
people are saying you know my god you
are you're my hero we're in this
together and some of them still identify
as Muslim they are not necessarily out
but they are they're thinking and you
and me and all the other liberals the
one thing we can advance is the idea of
critical thinking let's just give people
whether they are Muslim or not the
ability I mean just enhance their
ability to think critically about these
things yeah I love that I mean I that's
that's pretty much what I've tried to
now make my life about and it's clearly
what what you've done so really this has
been truly a thrill to spend a little
time with you and I hope I know you're
not going to be in LA probably for a
couple months but I hope we can do it in
person next time thank you so much thank
you for having me on David and good luck
with this with this show keep up the
good work
Thank You likewise all right well you
guys can buy ion's book it's called
heretic pretty much wherever books are
sold where do you want them to buy a
third you have a place you want to send
them and I don't know I mean it's yeah
buy whatever you can find it whatever is
convenient for you I guess
all right great well thank you so much I
on I really appreciate it thank you very
much thank you for having me